[Music]
so the book that we are launching with
is by summer rain Oaks it's a book
called how to make a plant love you
I met summer many many years ago we've
been close friends for a while and she
has she's just a powerhouse of an
optimist and a wonderful human being and
she has this fantastic idea about how to
raise plants how to look at the plants
her she's been featured in the press
multiple times because she has I don't
remember one hundred six hundred plants
in her New York City apartment in her
Brooklyn apartment and I've been think
it's up to seven I was up to seventh and
it's an amazing place to visit you know
you should have moved the vines out of
the way to wash the dishes and you know
it's really fantastic and she these
plants grow and thrive inside her New
York City apartment
and it's because it's not by luck it's
because she understands the plants she
understands where to put them and how to
nurture them and so we the way we treat
plants is we see a plant that we think
is pretty and we think oh it would look
nice over there on that coffee table and
we buy the plant we put on the coffee
table and the plant dies it's because we
bought the plant that we wanted and put
it where we wanted it and the reality is
you have to know where the plant wants
to be not where we want to put it and
you have to put it in the place where
it's more likely to thrive what I love
about summers work is it's a metaphor
because we do that with people we take
somebody we put them in the job that we
want them to do and then we get
frustrated that they don't succeed and
so we move them and they don't succeed
again but we never actually think to ask
where would they naturally thrive what
environment what position what job
should we put that person in so that
they'll do well though yes and on one
level summers book is actually a
wonderful book for people who want to
know more about how to look after plants
but there's really a very important and
deep-seated message contained within
this book about how to treat people
mm-hm it's it really it's a big metaphor
that if you learn how to take care of
plants how to make a plant level you're
actually learning how to make people
love you how to make people fall in love
with their jobs and each other it's just
it's just a wonderful and it's so full
of depth and she's such a talented
writer I I couldn't think of a better
book that I draw
I'd rather introduce the world to our
imprint with
[Music]
you